even making fun of me for telling you  that it's never too late that if you're  70 or 80  that it still can happen well what's the  biggest trend on Tick Tock grandparents  dominating if you're watching this right  now and your grandparent hit up those  grandkids and tell them it's [ __ ]  time for them to represent you and if  you're a grandkid call up Pops call up  gaga mama  whatever you call them and get their ass  into the content such a huge opportunity  and talk about a great boost of  connection and love and happiness and  joy and purpose for an entire generation  that should be admired I love that this  is happening it's a personal favorite of  mine and I'm really excited please leave  a comment if you consume any of that  content or if you've done this with your  grandparents or if they're considering  it now